let us understand the basics of
intersection intersection of lines and
intersection of
planes but what does intersect actually
mean it's simple it just means
meat if we have two lines line L and
line M which meet they are called
intersecting lines so what's special
about intersecting lines two
intersecting lines meet at exactly one
one point here we would say that lines l
and m intersect each other at Point
P there are a couple of interesting
things we need to know about
intersecting lines let us look at two
pairs of intersecting
lines the first pair is line a and line
B and the second pair is line C and line
D no matter how they meet they will form
exactly one plane line A and B form a
plane like this lines C and D form a
plane like
this this is the most important property
about intersecting lines two
intersecting lines always form a plane
let's erase this and look at an
interesting figure look at lines l and m
are these lines intersecting from what
you can see they are not meeting at a
point but wait one of the properties of
a line is that it extends infinitely in
both directions so when these two lines
are extended they meet at one single
point at this point this tells us that
they are intersecting lines two
intersecting lines always meet at a
point but what about three intersecting
lines we will see that in another
[Music]
video